♪ ♪
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
IN WASHINGTON SAY THEY ARE
FEELING VERY CONCERNED AFTER
LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE, BUT WHAT
DID VIEWERS THINK?
ISN’T TECHNICALLY THE PRESIDENT,
BUT HE IS EL PRESIDENTE.
HE CAME OUT LAST WEEK TO ASSESS
THAT DEBATE.
HE IS BACK TONIGHT.
DAVE, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
YOU WEREN’T SUPER IMPRESSED BY
BLOOMBERG LAST WEEK, I THINK IT
IS FAIR TO SAY.
YOU USED THE WORD "VOMIT"
SEVERAL TIMES IN YOUR ASSESSMENT
ASSESSMENT.
DID YOU REASSESS?
>> I DON’T THINK ANYBODY CAME
OUT LOOKING VERY GOOD.
HE BLENDED IN.
I’M NOT SITTING HERE SINGLING
HIM OUT.
THIS WAS A WAR, THIS WAS LIKE
"ANCHORMAN."
IT WAS SORT OF EMBARRASSING.
I DON’T KNOW, IF YOU WATCH THIS,
THEY ARE ALL RAISING THEIR HAND,
ALL SCREAMING OVER EACH OTHER.
I DON’T KNOW A
THEY DO IT ON A TON OF GAME
SHOWS, TIME IS UP, YOUR
MICROPHONE IS OFF.
I WOULD NEVER BE INTIMIDATED TO
STOP TALKING.
IF YOU TALK THE LONGEST AND THE
LOUDEST EVENTUALLY YOU GET THE
FLOOR.
I TWEETED THIS OUT, IF I WAS AN
ALIEN ON EARTH, AND THESE WERE
THE PEOPLE COMPETING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT, I WOULD INVADE.
IT IS EMBARRASSING.
I DON’T KNOW IF IT’S ANY
DIFFERENT BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, THEY JUST SCREAM AT
EACH OTHER AND LOOK LIKE MORONS,
AND KINDERGARTEN WITH NO
TEACHERS IN IT.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
>> Tucker: TWO QUESTIONS, WHY
WOULD YOU INVADE?
BECAUSE THEY LOOK SO WEAK THEY
ARE EASY TO TAKE OVER OR FOR
THEIR OWN GOOD, OR BOTH?
>> I WOULD PROBABLY INVADE BOTH
FOR THEIR OWN GOOD BUT THEY’RE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
EACH OTHER, BATTLING EACH OTHER
AND THEN WALK RIGHT BY THEM IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT’S LITERALLY INSANE.
THESE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
INTELLIGENT PEOPLE SCREAMING AT
EACH OTHER.
I WAS STOMACH WE JUST
LIVE, I WOULD THROW STATS,
FIGURES, NOBODY KNOWS IF IT’S
DRIVEN BY BY THE TIME
TOMORROW ROLLS AROUND, YEAH,
BIDEN CAN’T GO OUT INTO EVERYONE
IN AMERICA WAS KILLED BY GUNS
LAST YEAR BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
ALIVE BUT UNLESS YOU SCREW UP
THAT BADLY, NOBODY KNOWS.
IT’S JUST A SHOUTING FEST, THAT
IS ALL THAT IS.
THAT’S ALL POLITICS ARE.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT THE
MODERATORS?
WHAT IS THAT?
SHOULDN’T THEY BE KEEPING
CONTROL?
>> TUCKER, IT’S REALLY SIMPLE.
SHUT THE MICROPHONE OFF.
30 SECONDS, YOUR MICROPHONE IS
OFF, YOU’RE SCREAMING AT AIR.
IS THAT REVOLUTIONARY?
HOW HARD IS THAT YOU DO?
BUDDY, YOUR TIME IS UP COME ON
HE IS BANNED THEY DO IT ALL THE
TIME.
YOUR TIME IS UP, BEEP, YOU CAN’T
TALK ANYMORE.
AM I THE ONLY ONE TO THINK OF
THIS?
INSTEAD THEY SCREAM AT EACH
OTHER.
IT’S INSANE.
>> Tucker: YOU’VE GOT SOME
LOUD GUYS IN YOUR OFFICE.
YOU DON’T PUT UP WITH THIS KIND
OF STUFF, DO YOU?
>> THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
BUT HERE’S THE THING, OUR GUYS
AREN’T RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE IDIOTS.
EVERYONE LOOKS AT US AND SAYS,
THERE OUT THERE YELLING AT EACH
OTHER, LOCKER ROOM ENVIRONMENT,
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE CRITICIZING
US.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WE ARE.
BY THE WAY, I WANTED TO SAY
THIS, I’M WEARING AN ARMANI
SUIT, THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS
I CAME ON BECAUSE IF BERNIE GETS
ELECTED I DIDN’T WANT HIM TO
STEAL IT FOR ME SO I WANTED TO
GET SOME USE OUT OF.
>> Tucker: IF ELIZABETH WARREN
GETS ELECTED, YOU’RE GOING
STRAIGHT TO PRISON.
[LAUGHS]
>> WHO KNOWS WHAT THEY’RE DOING.
THEY’RE GOING TO BE TOO BUSY --
AGAIN, I’M SMARTER THAN THEY
ARE, THEY JUST YELL AT EACH
OTHER AND I GO AROUND THE
CORNER.
HONESTLY, SHUT THE MICROPHONES
OFTEN THIS ISN’T JUST
DEMOCRAT-REPUBLICAN, THEY SCREAM
AT EACH OTHER, MAKE STUFF UP,
WHO KNOWS, HOW DO I PICK WHAT
HAPPENED?
HOW COULD ANYBODY PICK BETWEEN
THESE PEOPLE?
HOW?